hi this is presh talwicker in this video
we'll discuss a long division puzzle
all right here's the problem you have a
six digit number starting with six
divided by three digit number ending in
nine that results in a three digit
number ending in five and three
can you figure out what the missing
digits are
in other words can you fill in the rest
of these boxes to make this long
division problem work out
so this problem has been around for
about a hundred years popularized by the
puzzle maker sam lloyd
and you should give it a try
when you're ready you can keep watching
to see how i figured out
the problem
all right so what i would do is there's
a lot of
information here so we're going to try
and focus on just one piece at a time
so the first step of the long division
procedure is we have
nine
times this number that's missing
and that'll end up with the units digit
of two
so we wanna think what times nine
could end up with the units digit of two
going through the different
possibilities
this only happens when we have nine
times eight which is seventy-two
so that means this missing digit here
has to be an eight
and this is useful information because
that means we know the result has to be
853
the next thing i would try and do is
figure out the second digit
next to the nine
so we know the result is 853
and we're dividing by something that has
a units digit of nine
so if we multiply three by nine
that has to give us
the units digit of
the very last number that we end up with
so we know this number at the very end
has to be a 7.
now since there's no remainder
the number above it has to be seven
and also the tens digit has to be a four
so that
47 minus 47 cancels out
so now we need to figure out
something that has like 19 29
so on
multiplied by three that'll have the
last two digits of four and seven
and going through the possibilities
the only way this will happen is if we
have 49
so we can already deduce
the second digit will be
a four
now we only have one more number that's
missing which is the hundred spots in
our three digit number
so how can we figure that out
well we know the result is a six-digit
number that's 608
or you know more than 600 000 uh less
than 700 000 so we'll do some estimation
so in order to get the answer to be a
six digit number that has a leading
digit of six
the only answer could really be
something around seven hundred and fifty
so we know that this digit actually has
to be a seven
and
that's pretty much all the information
we need once we know that
uh we have
we're dividing by 749 the result is 853
we can go and reverse and multiply these
two numbers
that'll get us what the original number
is
638
897
and from there we can just do the
problem as normal and we can figure out
all of the room the missing digits
so here is the solution
i hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker and you can
get my books listed on my website